Tick Tock content that is disintegrating
America or reducing patriotic feelings
towards it is generated by us in America
yeah this isn't the Chinese creating
content but because of the dynamic of
audience capture and the reinforcement
mechanism of getting that status
response you can press your hand on the
scale that rewards creators that create
a particular type of narrative it's so
brilliant and Insidious at the same time
and by the way let's wrap all of this in
really joyous Dance videos which makes
it all feel really benign you don't even
have to put your thumb on the scale of
certain individuals and not others it
can be the content from the same
individual in the same 60 Minutes an
individual will have Pro and
anti-American content and we're just
going to slowly but surely dial up the
anti-American content I would argue 90
plus percent of the thoughtful discourse
about vaccines says on a risk-adjusted
basis you should get a vaccine and then
10 or less is doctors saying it Alters
your DNA if I'm the CCP and I want to
create controversy and I want to get us
hating each other more let's make that
content 50 50. let's have everyone go at
each other